[Music]
it
is time for back to school for some
students at private schools that means
it's time to
actually head back to the classroom for
students at ccsd they'll be distance
learning online in two weeks time and
for others in charter and other private
schools
it will be a blend of both thank you for
joining us for this back to school
special i'm kirsten joyce and i'm brian
loftis good evening we know you have a
lot of questions so for the next half
hour
we'll be giving you answers that have
been figured out and telling you what
you need to know
in order to get ready for all of it for
ccsd school starts on august 24
students will be starting the school
year entirely through distance education
the school district put information
about that in a back to school family
guide
kate houston breaks down how it can help
you prepare for the upcoming year
this 28-page document lays out how ccsd
will move forward with full-time
distance learning it goes over
everything from access to technology
meal distribution and the
responsibilities of families and
teachers
the digital guide is meant to be a
one-stop resource for the 320 thousand
students in the district when it comes
to scheduling there will be time
allocated for synchronous or real-time
learning and asynchronous or independent
learning
schedules and weekly instructional
guides will be provided to families by
their school
that's i think the biggest shift for
teachers now
because we weren't really sure how our
lessons were going to look
but now we know that we're going to have
to have time where we need to actually
be giving a live lesson to our students
the guide references how the district
will offer access and resources to
students with disabilities and
english language learners melissa ruiz's
eight-year-old son has an iep
she wishes the district went into more
detail on their plan
i think they did rest a little bit they
need to be more
precise on how it's going to work during
the virtual learnings
a lot of kids they do need that extra
hands-on
with the teachers one major challenge
the district is facing is how to give
every child access to the internet and a
device
ccsd is trying to acquire 76 thousand
chromebooks by fall
the guide states that schools are
reaching out to families directly to
assess their needs
with all of these changes the district
is offering parents academic
and emotional training opportunities
those will be available in live sessions
and pre-recorded content kate houston
8 news now the chief academic officer
for ccsd will be joining us live later
in this show and we will ask her to
really zero in on the plan
for those ieps and english language
learner students
and as you just heard brian the school
district has ordered some 76
000 chromebooks by the fall as of right
now the district has not said exactly
how many of those
it has received now schools are handing
them out as they get them
we caught up with staff at spring valley
high school where about 1 000 were
needed there
if your child need one needs one excuse
me you've been asked to fill out a
survey
go to the maine school district website
where it inquires about
technology and if you need help with
internet access
also remember to update your contact
information on the infinite campus
now once those students get chromebooks
they'll have to get online and the
school district will consider purchasing
discounted cox connect
internet for about 20 thousand students
they'll be talking about that during the
board meeting this week
ccsd's back to school website also has a
list of businesses supplying hot
spots and as for those wi-fi buses the
district used at the end of last year
they may be deployed on an as-needed
basis
brian about two-thirds of the students
in ccsd get free or reduced
breakfast and lunch for many it's really
the only way they'll get a meal during
the day
here is ccsd's plan food will be handed
out at more than 300 sites district-wide
starting august 24th
the meal pickup times will be staggered
with elementary first
then middle school then high school
parents picking up food should have the
student id their grade in what school
they attend they will pick up breakfast
and lunch at the same time
now ccsd says they are still figuring
out how transportation options will work
for students
who need the food dropped off they say
that information will go out via parent
link when finalized
ccsd also applied for a waiver that
would allow all
students to receive free and reduced
lunches they are still waiting to hear
back from the federal government
on if that was approved with all the
uncertainty
about how the school year will play out
you might be wondering what's going to
happen with traffic
right around those school zones will
there be or won't there be flashing
lights
our traffic anchor nate tannenbaum has
the answers
well like everything else these days
it's complicated first we have to wait
to see if or when on-site classroom
learning resumes
if when that happens we all should know
what the deal is even if we might be a
lot of practice
whether it's 15 miles an hour 20 or 25
when those lights are flashing that's
your speed limit
lives are at stake and oh the the
contents of your wallet might be as well
from hefty fines
so even when schools were closed in the
final months of the last school year
some campuses sometimes kept their lives
flashing it was all about which schools
were being used as food distribution
sites
and you might expect that at least at
the start of the 2021 school year
stay tuned now here's something you may
not know about who controls those
flashing lights
it's not the regional transportation
commission and it's not exactly the
school district itself
as we mentioned today what's driving you
crazy story back in may
each local entity controls the school
flashers in their jurisdictions
in other words if a school's in
henderson flashing lights are controlled
by henderson
same for north las vegas and for las
vegas in other words there is no
one entity that controls the flashers
for all schools in the school district
how about that so to learn which
campuses are food distribution sites and
may have flashing lights now
we've got a link to not only the sites
but also their menus
back to you all right thanks nate we put
all that info in our back to school
section
it's over on eight newsnow.com well some
students will
physically return to the classroom up
next in our back to school special we'll
look at the rules and precautions being
taken
at various private and charter schools
plus what will school athletics look
like this year if there
are any we take a look at how football
and basketball teams are expected to
play out the remainder of this year